there's now a three-digit number to call
or text if you're experiencing a mental
health crisis 988 is the new national
suicide and crisis hotline experts
believe it will help more people access
the support they need during an
emergency madison kimbrough joins us
live from the newsroom tonight with more
madison 988 is our nation's first mental
health crisis hotline designed to
connect callers with trained mental
health counselors just like 9-1-1 would
be for police or paramedics now starting
today the national suicide hotline
officially added three numbers to their
already existing toll-free 10-digit
number of
1-800-273 talk with the intent of
eventually replacing it with 988 in the
future that 1-800 hotline has already
existing networks of over 200 crisis
centers nationwide staffed by counselors
who answer millions of calls each year
misty von allen suicide prevention
coordinator for southern nevada says
this is a huge step in the right
direction in recognizing the efforts and
effects of mental health with that that
they hope that those who call will do so
before things escalate
mental health challenges relationships
and concerns and thoughts of suicide are
some of the leading reasons people reach
out to a hotline
but our ideal situation is early
intervention
so we don't want them to have to wait
until that crisis of suicide to reach
out and call for support
and with the demand growing crisis
support services of nevada say so has
their response time as they've been able
to answer over 90 percent of calls in a
matter of 25 seconds now the new
three-digit 988 lifeline is expected to
serve 7.6 million americans in crisis in
its first year in the newsroom madison
kimbrough live local now